LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
I'm Louis Gray, here with my
special guest, Chris Wilson
from the Google Chrome team.
Welcome, Chris.
CHRIS WILSON: Thanks, Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: Chris, this
is a special treat.
We both get to stand
up a little bit.
And we're going to talk
about some fun things,
including Web Audio.
We've had you on Google
Developers Live a
couple of times now.
CHRIS WILSON: You have,
actually, to
talk about Web Audio.
LOUIS GRAY: Talk about
Web Audio.
I mean, this is really a
specialty and a passion for
you, as you've told me.
CHRIS WILSON: Yes.
Yes, it is definitely
a passion in my
personal life, too.
So I kind of carried that
over into my work life.
LOUIS GRAY: And you live
up in Seattle, right?
CHRIS WILSON: I do currently.
Although I'm in the process
of moving down here.
LOUIS GRAY: Seattle's kind of
appropriate, where you let
your hair down--
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: --get
the guitar out.
So it all just kind of
works very smoothly.
CHRIS WILSON: Get the whole
grunge look going, and we'll
see how it works down here.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
So on the Chrome team, we really
talk about three things
most of the time.
And it's speed.
It's simplicity.
And it's security.
CHRIS WILSON: Yes.
LOUIS GRAY: But with the Web
Audio, you're also trying to
make the web do more.
CHRIS WILSON: Absolutely.
LOUIS GRAY: Tell me a little
bit about what's
going on with Web Audio.
CHRIS WILSON: So one of the
goals with Web Audio was first
to make it so that we could do
really good audio for gaming,
for any kind of interactive
application where you wanted
to be able to precisely
time things.
You hit the Fire button, you
don't want to hear it sometime
in the future.
You want to hear it right when
you hit the Fire button.
You want to be able
to do all kinds of
processing on that too.
And you want to be able to
synchronize things together,
too, which has been really
hard to do in the web
platform, prior to Web Audio.
And now with Web Audio, you
can actually do that.
We also have a really powerful
processing system.
So you can do reverb and another
convolution effects.
You can do filtering effects.
You can place things in a 3D
sound field, and all kinds of
other neat stuff that is really
interesting for gaming,
of course, like all
those things.
Immersive games really need
those kinds of features.
But you also really want the
ability to do more than that
for kind of regular digital
audio workstation synthesis
kind of stuff as well.
LOUIS GRAY: Like professional
musicians and
that kind of stuff.
When you look at the verticals
that are here, not only games,
but what other type of people
are really going to be looking
at Web Audio as a solution
for them?
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
Well, I think that gaming, first
and foremost, was what
we had to hit just to begin,
just to get off the ground.
And now we're starting to carry
over into some of these
more professional audio
applications.
And we're starting to see a lot
of people come out of the
woodwork and start building
applications that do things
like drum machines, and
synthesizers, and other
processing type stuff as well.
And that's really I think what
I'm here to talk about today,
is kind of where we've come
since last year at I/O. Last
year at I/O, I gave a talk
about Web Audio--
still up on YouTube of course.
Got tons of great information.
I think almost all of that is
still completely relevant and
really a great--
LOUIS GRAY: But since then,
we've introduced new APIs.
CHRIS WILSON: We
have, actually.
LOUIS GRAY: We've made phones
stronger, faster.
And I think you actually bought
a couple demos for us.
CHRIS WILSON: I did.
LOUIS GRAY: Maybe you can
introduce us to what this demo
is all about.
CHRIS WILSON: Sure.
LOUIS GRAY: And let's get
the instruments out.
You didn't bring a drum
machine, did you?
CHRIS WILSON: I didn't bring a
drum machine, although I do
have a drum machine app
on my demos page.
LOUIS GRAY: No doubt.
CHRIS WILSON: So you
can check it out.
But one of the things I wanted
to start with was when I did
the Web Audio talk
last year, I was
exploring the API myself.
And what I did to explore it
was I built a vocoder.
And for anybody who remembers
kind of early '80s synth rock,
a vocoder is like the robotic
voice effect.
So you got this, really it's
a processing effect.
I'm not into tons of details.
LOUIS GRAY: Sort of Kraftwerk
to information society.
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: I like that stuff
way too much, to be honest.
CHRIS WILSON: The domo arigato
thing, that was all vocoding.
And so vocoding, takes a
frequency analysis of one
audio sound.
And it maps that frequency
analysis over time under a
different audience sound.
And I did this demo as
part of my talk.
And I didn't go into a ton of
depth, because there was a lot
of code that I built for it.
But one of the exciting things
that I was really hoping we
would get in before I/O last
year, but it missed.
We were in summer I
think, midsummer,
before we got it in--
was audio input.
So not only can you generate
these sounds on the computer--
play back pre-recorded audio
snippets or build things with
synthesis--
but you can actually get audio
input from the computer.
LOUIS GRAY: From live
audio, as well.
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
So you can get the microphone on
your computer or any other
audio source that's
plugged into it.
LOUIS GRAY: And I understand
you brought an
audio source today.
CHRIS WILSON: You can use
that and process it.
I did.
LOUIS GRAY: Let's see it.
CHRIS WILSON: I brought a couple
of them, actually.
So we're going to start, I want
to show-- the vocoder was
the first app that I was like,
as soon as I got a build from
the developer, I was like,
oh I got to go add this.
And like my wife was there
making dinner.
And I'm like yeah, don't
bother me right now.
I'm busy.
So I got this up and running
in about 20, 25 minutes.
And basically I took this audio
vocoder that I built,
which could work off of a
preprocessed sound source.
So let's play and you can hear
of what it sounds like.
LOUIS GRAY: You're playing that
off the computer now.
CHRIS WILSON: And we're
playing it off the
computer right now.
So this is all being--
I prerecorded myself talking and
then applied the vocoding
effect to it.
So now, I can take this and
just click my little live
input button.
And I have a live
audio source.
LOUIS GRAY: Are you going
to sing for us?
CHRIS WILSON: Check the
microphone, right here.
I'm not going to sing for you.
I actually told one of my
coworkers, singing--
not really something I'm
prepared to do yet.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
No singing today.
Sorry guys.
CHRIS WILSON: Sorry,
not this time.
So one of the things that we do
here of course, is we have
to ask, is it OK if we use
your audio input source?
Because we don't want to let any
random web page pop up and
say, oh sure, you can listen
in to all of your users.
LOUIS GRAY: Oh, absolutely.
Permission first.
Security.
CHRIS WILSON: So permission
first.
Security is always
the theme here.
But now you can tell, I actually
have this vocoder
effect on my voice.
Everything that I say is running
through this vocoding
processing effect.
And by the way, all of the code
that I'm doing here--
and maybe we should stop doing
vocoding effect, because it's
probably a little
bit distracting.
We could use this for the
rest of the talk.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure.
CHRIS WILSON: But all of this
processing is actually being
done by the Web Audio API.
My own code actually
just sets up this
whole network of nodes.
And then the audio processing
API does everything.
The only bit of my JavaScript
code that's running right now
is the stuff that animates that
neat little visual effect
on the screen.
So the next thing though, like
the next thing that I built
after I added this into the
vocoder, was just started
playing with some
input effects.
LOUIS GRAY: And which
input is this?
CHRIS WILSON: So this is still
pulling off the microphone.
And it's just a few simple
effects, like delay.
But I'm going to turn this
off for a second.
And one of the things that is
really important to understand
is that input isn't
just microphones.
It's not just the mic that's
plugged into your computer.
So what I've got hooked up here
is just a standard USB
audio input.
But I have the ability
to plug-in
different audio sources.
And I brought along
my trusty guitar.
LOUIS GRAY: That's
a nice guitar.
Are you going to
show everybody?
CHRIS WILSON: It is
a nice guitar.
This is my baby.
This is one of my babies.
This is my electric baby.
But so what I've got
running off here--
and I'm going to pick a
different sound here, just so
we can see it.
What I've got running here is
just a regular, quarter-inch
output out of my guitar, run
straight into the USB audio.
In fact, I can change
the effect mix here.
And you can hear what
it sounds like.
It's kind of twangy.
It's standard kind of thing.
But if I crank the effects mix
up, what you'll hear is me
playing running through effects
that are all being
done in Web Audio.
I just set up a bunch of nodes
to do various things in here.
So this is my bass effects.
I didn't want to bring my bass
along because that was way too
much to take on the plane.
LOUIS GRAY: And while you're
doing that, we can all see the
visual running through the
computer at the same time.
CHRIS WILSON: Yeah.
So I've already talked about one
of the first things we had
to do was this precise
timing of audio.
We had to give you the ability
to precisely schedule things,
set them up, synchronize them,
do things together.
And I've got a bunch of other
really great stuff too that I
don't want to get into today,
because it takes a while.
But there's lot of powerful
stuff you can do with that
scheduling.
And then we added all this
processing stuff.
Like the things you're seeing
here are all filters and
convolution effects, distortion
using wave shaping,
and things like that.
But the last thing that the Web
Audio API really has is a
great ability to do analysis,
like we have built in
FFT-based frequency analysis.
LOUIS GRAY: What kind
of analysis?
CHRIS WILSON: So you can
actually see as I'm playing
here, this is a frequency
break down.
In fact, I can switch this
to just a straightforward
frequency graph.
And you can see the rich
harmonics because this wah
bass effect is actually trimming
off all the higher
frequencies.
It clips all the stuff that's on
there to the right, because
of course, lower frequencies
are on the left here.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
CHRIS WILSON: But if I switch to
something else, like just a
distorted effect, you can see
the distorted effect has lots
of high-end energy.
And this is all being done, all
of the analysis of this is
being done, by the
Web Audio API.
So I have code of course, that
goes in and pulls the numbers
out and draws them
on the screen--
draws them on an HTML5 canvas.
But I'm not actually having to
do the processing of the bits
in JavaScript.
LOUIS GRAY: A lot of this, this
is programs that you've
written based on the
Web Audio API.
Now, a couple of questions.
Number one, is the Web Audio API
always available in every
Chrome install, or is
it something else
you have to go get?
CHRIS WILSON: It's
a great question.
The Web Audio API is actually
available in
Chrome across the board.
It's not something
you need to add.
As I showed before, you do have
to, your users have to
allow microphone input,
live audio input.
They have to say it's OK to be
able to get access to that.
LOUIS GRAY: And then the second
thing I was going to
ask is, how do developers
get started with this?
If there's somebody who really
wants to either look through
the Web Audio API to add it to
their games, or find some
other way to manipulate sound,
what do they do?
CHRIS WILSON: I think
there are a lot of
demos out there now.
There's a lot of code
out there now.
All of these things
by the way, are on
webaudiodemos.appspot.com.
You actually just search
for Web Audio demos.
This comes up.
LOUIS GRAY: It can
be number one.
CHRIS WILSON: This is
number one, I think.
I'm pretty sure this is
still number one.
LOUIS GRAY: In all
major engines.
CHRIS WILSON: Yes.
And this has a whole
bunch of my demos.
You can see most of these
have a link to
the Repro and GitHub.
These are all open
source stuff.
You can take it in and do
whatever you want with it.
But I forgot where
I was going now.
LOUIS GRAY: You were
talking about how
we're going to develop.
You said it's on GitHub.
You can find it at web.appspot.
Yeah.
CHRIS WILSON: The one thing I
did want to say is, one of the
other things and I'm really
excited about this year is
we're just on the cusp of
getting all this stuff into
Chrome for Android.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
I was going to ask
about mobile.
Yes.
CHRIS WILSON: We're starting to
get all of this processing
power on the web platform on
mobile devices as well.
LOUIS GRAY: Interesting.
CHRIS WILSON: This is a much
more challenging thing to do,
because there's a broad spectrum
of devices and audio
hardware and those devices.
LOUIS GRAY: But there's been
some of that simplicity.
CHRIS WILSON: But it's
super powerful.
LOUIS GRAY: You had Android
studio, that just came out
which is going really help
people be able to code Android
applications against many
different models and types and
see how that works.
And as you look in Chrome,
Chrome came off Android not
too long ago.
It's out on IOS as well now.
And it's very interesting to
see that once you start
writing for a specific platform,
and that platform
becomes available to different
people on different operating
systems and different handsets,
it's just really
ubiquitous.
And it's available everywhere.
CHRIS WILSON: Exactly.
That's really the thing had me
really excited about Web Audio
from the beginning, was the idea
that eventually, we would
get this everywhere.
We would get it as a ubiquitous
platform.
I don't need to have a
particular device.
I actually, as I've been
preparing to move, I've been
packing up my studio.
And I've had to think through
each piece like, am I really
going to need this anymore?
Because by the time I unpack,
I could rebuild a bunch of
this stuff just as
Web Audio APIs.
And I don't really
need to drag the
hardware around anymore.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
CHRIS WILSON: Like what I
brought here with me today,
what I brought with me down to
I/O, was basically just a USB
audio input, one microphone,
one guitar, and no effects
boxes or anything like that.
LOUIS GRAY: Awesome.
CHRIS WILSON: And I can still
there are tons of neat stuff.
LOUIS GRAY: Thank you for
bringing all that stuff over.
Thanks for joining us
with your guitar--
CHRIS WILSON: Thank
you for having me.
LOUIS GRAY: --and all
of your equipment.
It seems like we ran really
fast through this.
So I definitely want
people to check out
webaudio.appspot.com.
CHRIS WILSON: Webaudiodemos.
LOUIS GRAY: Webaudiodemos,
thank you--
webaudiodemos.appspot.com.
Thanks for joining me, Chris.
We have Chris on a regularly
on GDL and
all the Chrome team.
So definitely follow us at
developers.google.com/live,
and subscribe to Google
Developers on YouTube.
We're going to be right back in
a couple of minutes to talk
about YouTube, and the Sandbox,
and wrap our I/O
programming.